This is the house in Beirut that Carlos Ghosn is said to have fled to,...
...but there is no sign of him here;...
...just lights and the security guards outside saying he is not at home.
Many Lebanese view the former Nissan CEO as a successful businessman...
...and is a symbol of their country's large diaspora.
But in Tokyo, the unexpected turn of events has sparked outrage.
Ghosn's escape to Lebanon is the latest stunning twist in a roller coaster journey...
...that saw him fall from boardroom  to detention center.
Here, he spent more than 100 days in Spartan conditions,...
...far removed from his sometimes extravagant lifestyle.
The automotive tycoon  stands accused of underreporting his salary...
...to the tune of 85 million dollars.
Prosecutors also alleged he skimmed off millions of dollars from the company...
...for his personal use.
Japan does not have an extradition treaty with Lebanon,...
...so it's unclear what steps Tokyo might take next.